hello and welcome to this video playing
at arises again titan recently in some
kind of chat um what was that and modern
been only I think check so let's see
what happens here in this BOGO and I can
also go with an e five base set up here
you today i play with be six but this is
quite clearly also a solid option ok no
it's and put some stuff in the center
see how it plays with be five okay you
know make some sense while it's probably
slightly better him we've got the two
bishops a for Bishop e3 may be coming
and what I have at least has some some
good piss on the Kings side I wonder
okay I think I'll do that it looks
beginning but a six is also a problem
blacks idea is a piece based attack on
the kingside Bishop g4 is my next move
if you place something like Bishop e3
for example
yeah here may be the same thing even
though night h4 is also interesting yeah
let's do this it's also kind of
interesting
black black players shouldn't be
underestimated I have some some pieces
near the gang yeah this is all looking
looking nice and good but this night is
not doing anything for the defense so
okay let's see I work for Queen to g5
now on the queenside are basically
busted but yea even taking on g2 now is
yeah it's a threat to take on g2 here
almost maybe I do threaten this close
we'll see what happens
tonight you to change it to Queen age
for this is definitely super dangerous
okay if he goes age 3 i'll play night
age 64 Queen g5 next happy having
provoked his weakness
okay is taking a long time yes it's not
easy to play this this stuff ok I think
here probably 25 is the right move now
g2 is Bishop takes GF 1 so let's bring
the Queen into this threatening 92 now
yes what here neither 3 is not possible
one thing is not good i cannot believe I
cannot look left and this is this is not
great and let's go back
probably threatening Queen to h5 queen
age 5 h 4 90 x g4 is a latex h4 is a win
so yep trying stuff like that if i go to
age 5 probably give to wear if we win
they exchange and i still prefer to open
the same this one okay taking all you
three seems impossible but here right
threatening on h2 + + h 4 i'm going to
go into sacrifice yeah i cannot he
cannot cover all this stuff and yeah
hurtling Queen h2 Queen age one mate
that's not going to be defendable I
think any porn piece to have one is chip
made no that's all yeah this attack is
not to be underestimated on the King
side they've nylon see file simply not
defending at all just doesn't help
don't see a move here hey this one that
I overlooked but I don't I don't see
anything yeah okay this is not not an
immediate check made huh Chad it should
be the right one and still so if i go
here on h1 king it to quincy to check a
king in one still don't see a major
there really should be one but i don't
see it as we had probably just me a bag
that i don't see them they win here
check
93 and then I Bishop g4 so it doesn't
doesn't really seem to win now hmm
this one may be still whom I'm kind of
amazed that I didn't didn't find
anything better anything more convinced
I'm morning can check check should you
fall to say anything better cannot use
my rook Seattle this is a real shame I
take this one in and actually timewise
it's not so brilliant come on kick with
the bloody rope here or it doesn't
really help much amazing amazing that I
didn't get got more here check check
just try to be pragmatic yet when
blundering the a porn shoot this is
really bad that was a bad blunder I know
I'm actually in a bad shape Wow check
check
check check check mate who what the hook
I didn't find a chick matey in this
position actually sorry he was would
give up and then be busy and I have no
mate this is chris is crazy i have no
checkmate here check this rupee eight
it's the engine move will probably make
some sense it wants to take on his three
maybe em and then enter check that the
session isn't that clears what the cost
of the worst part i was looking looking
looking and check didn't didn't find a
mate and it seems to be better though
chan yeah that's better hmm that was the
wind bishop your flag and check and this
is actually not that clear the engine is
on equal okay here queen age to was
winning and then c3 and okay okay this
is not clear at all check check and here
it's probably a doctor blunder and a 6
i'm just lost their yes on some Becky's
time scramble wow wow I didn't really
expect that there was some resistance
possible but the position wasn't wasn't
clear at all whoa tough game thanks for
watching